c'est loupé deux particules hier qui me
tient à coeur que je peux pas exprimer
comme ça c'est kelly on dire pourquoi et
l'ambiance est ce que tu proposes
vraiment c'est important que je propose
mais comme menu tous les sources à la
capelle il a donné la formule à 12 ans
de tyrannie ont proposées coûtent
hanouna propose un menu avec un tiramisu
à 12 euros 50 est une bombe
messieurs je peut se traduire si vous
voulez oui allez-y mais en fait dans qui
il voudrait vous dira tout l'amour qu'il
voue pas parce que tous les soirs et
passants se faire beaux moments avec
avec nous et il est vraiment ravi est
super heureux il n'a jamais été aussi
heureux de nous rejoindre et fait donc
en deuxième langue maxi que je tiens
aussi à vous tirer j'aurais tellement
aimé qu'il se présente à la formation du
gign
[Rires]
non en fait aussi bon
oui j'ai fait le service militaire à
l'époque c'était encore on était obligé
de 60 ans quand elle était majeure
et en fait je fais en fait je alors la
question c'est sais quoi et où
en fait je gérais opposer quand je
travaille avec toi et je donne et on
revient en arrière
la surcharge beau parce que dans ma
grotte mais son cerf-volant radars déjà
skié grâce à toi et je sais que tu fais
du bien de ton côté grâce à toi et à
beaucoup de bien qui fait du mien mais
apparemment elle comprend bien d'autres
gynéco va écouter merci qui dit on a
trouvé votre fonction dans l'émission ça
va un peu plus charrier